hi guys I'm Greg no I'm John ghost in
the shell' movieclip building jump
this is requested from go full he said
it's freakin cool go fool I'm planning
on watching ghosts in the show next week
the animated movie before the movie
comes out we're trying to figure out how
we can do a watch along one of those
things yeah yeah yeah Gelinas join us
don't mark my words on that but yeah
[Music]
pretty happy shot they got there I'm ill
I'm floor by race change and admin I was
nothing I can't do nothing nothing I
can't know something I can't be
[Music]
my four-year-old daughter time it's okay
to sing that lullaby speak fluent French
serene practicing hotel security network
I buy music
got it 43rd floor someone contact
president's down someone watching him
what is it you want the one that I gets
more about when anchor robotics can do
for you 73% this world open up to the
age cyber NASA really want to be left
behind my people embrace divert
announcements as do i no one really
understands the individuality I did yes
he acts identical Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
that's a bitchin suit barely a suit Oh
[Music]
who sent you answer me
collaborate we think of a bottom can be
destroyed see an answer though yeah okay
desert een yeah I only had better naked
woman kicking ass right there there was
a naked lady she's not naked already
naked Lee she's not naked broad dozen
Bourbons in pretty big googly ah
whatever John I'm just surprised that at
pg-13 Lee I'm surprised because usually
usually we're not very chill about sex
but we are about violence she's not
naked basically naked is just a skin
tight outfit it's super duper formative
a man raising form that hey dude we over
sexualized our Hale heroes too fine you
know so what part of the movies and
she's not naked it's clearly a suit it
just looks like skin it's not a
see-through outfit it just looks like a
skin that have made it incredibly humid
but it's not a see-through I know it's
not the same thing but I'm just still
like it seems like the finished possible
barrier between this and a very hard are
maybe like you can have like this is a
prolonged sequence like you can have
less literal nudity and get harder
writing and this is like you know it's
not the saintly well it's kind of
weirding me out about the clip because I
thought the movie was rated R for some
reason it feels like it would be I mean
I I haven't yet to see the the original
no neither have I I don't think those
pg-13 material but Mike my comment that
I was going to make was I was watching
the clip and I was thinking this could
be like pg-13 actually and then it said
pg-13 and I was like oh if there's
something about it that just was kind of
missing a sort of violent Griffin its
tone for me yeah and they're shooting
robots and [ __ ]
no need for blood and all that I feel
like it's more hard when they have skin
so they should still be some blood if I
don't know how to roll video from the
Michelle machines work your that that's
the thing that makes you wonder about
this movie more than anything cuz like
this is a really cool clip like you know
it looks visually amazing you know it's
a rollicking sort of a scene
maybe I watched the movie and be like
yeah TVs are seeing a good fit for this
but like this is almost like the matrix
you know at certain points or you know
Kill Bill is like shooting up dudes and
stuff and yeah it feels like it would
lose something after a while if they
can't go all the way yeah it seemed like
a pretty mature film you know yeah what
I could gather about the original SD
prison I was like sold it to be radar I
had no question about it yeah I may be
good the jelly money you know we haven't
seen the original yet yeah maybe I maybe
I'm Robbie hey hey I mean like as just
as a clip just purely as a clip from a
sci-fi film called ghosts from the show
pretty freakin cool I mean this has a
lot of the imagery that I like I mean I
like weird futuristic dystopia with
Holograms and kuru becomes doing all the
design is up is cool and they pretty
much showed us a lot of that action
scenes from the trailer yeah yeah which
one which I thought was awesome I'm some
of the first time I saw well well oh
this is a pretty sweet action so yeah
visually this looks very appealing style
look very appealing something about the
lack of violent I don't know is
expecting even though they're robots for
that bit you know yeah I'm so used to
like especially from my West world now
that we ever you know robots with with
skin tissue it shoppers still like what
it is that way are like no bloody here
they did a little bit like when when
they what a couple of got shot in the
face there was like this white milky
liquid and I thought that was a cool
touch but it didn't carry over
it's just that about this movie I'm
curious about how Scarlett Johansson is
gonna be as the lead aside for all the
controversy analysis like what her
performance is gonna be like yeah yeah
well it's because in the it was she's
white and the you
me she's black I do remember that from
some facts that happened in real life
yeah right now I'm just being she's like
repeating information like describing
things and then you know shooting people
ya know it's giving you an idea for the
town in this style and the world that
it's building upon it you know and I
like conversations that take place in
futuristic sci-fi worlds where they're
just talking with in the world like of
how these characters will talk about
things like when they exchange at the
dinner table where they're at and how
they're spending information playing it
back and forth yeah I like how it didn't
feel like exposition to me I have to pay
attention to catch on it was a bunch of
dog you know this much is being told to
me directly I think it's all looking
together really well this feels like
it's probably the opening of the film I
think this is a really good clip because
you know could be anyone can make a cool
trailer but in terms of like being
engaged into an actual scene I found
myself easily able to watch the scene
why is every sci-fi movie have that kind
of song oh it was like oh so much
synthesizers yeah like an arpeggiator
yeah every sci-fi movie yes yeah our
dangers of we just saw yesterday as some
of that music in the air yeah
the transformer trailer has about fun
we're also we're also in the 80s
nostalgia thing like like those those
like heavy sin analog items soundtrack
sir I feel like right now the app punk
composed the music for Tron that's when
we started seeing a lot of movies and
shows bring that kind of song back I got
a music back I feel like it had
something to do with them and I feel
like it had something to do with even
even Hans Zimmer's work I'm like The
Dark Knight and stuff like that because
like that became a style of score music
and he used a lot of like arpeggiated
staccato known yeah okay I like it I
always liked it let's get into the point
it's like when I hear you know covered
for a song in a trailer it's it's at
that point for me
my marriage is in so many movies the
second movie for Rupert Sanders here so
oh the guy who played wrong yeah he's
really a Harry Potter [ __ ] Rupert
Sanders of Harry Potter face yeah man
and this I feel like this is like
Watchmen again this is a big piece and
you gotta [ __ ] nail it dude
and you know like the next fighter I
think there was some stuff in the watch
from me it's moving it's beautiful like
movies like these I'm always really on
edge about even when I was a kid before
I even got into anime for a while before
I was a kid I knew what goes to the show
what like I'd seen the tape yeah and so
I guess I don't know it just seems like
it is part of like the cultural Canon
yeah Liguria so how's it going to turn
out let's just hope they can have this
movie can have a personality and
characters we can get on board with it's
gotta be great it's like it has to be
great like that's what I'm worried I
mean River standards like I didn't I
didn't love his last movie that's why
but I think he's got a really great eye
I don't know I guess there's ways on the
writer for well dude I mean we just mean
movies for cool trailers we don't need
actual good movie don't say things like
then no I'm hoping I'm hoping Hollywood
listening so they can know this is what
we want we don't care about the actual
movie as long as the trailers are cool
that's what can but maybe that is true
because maybe this keeps happening maybe
we keep getting the same kinds of movies
because what we really really love about
all this is the anticipation because the
anticipation is much fun well meeting
maybe I just think that you know we need
we need to sell some [ __ ] tickets on
opening night because there's always a
goddamn huge movie coming up next week
yeah every weeks a big movie
yeah yeah you know you just gotta make
sure you make a [ __ ] ton of money that
opening weekend so you got to have a
cool trailer you don't really need a
good movie the DCU has proven isn't it I
yeah subscribe is the real reject John
is all his [ __ ] the description boxes go
there already and click that
notification bell if you wish to good
bye